alors mon chéri on grain combien
200 c'est les prix mon chéri tu es pas
la
Samaritaine combien je ne fais pas j'ai
mal aux
dents vous appelez comment
Simon et
avant j'ai du mal à me
rappeler
mon prénom de baptême ou ils se sont
trompés c'était al dans ma tête et sur
mon front j'ai toujours eu le
sexe que je
souhaitais
c'estd un sexe
féminin se donner une image de femme
c'est un long
cheminement
il faut d'abord se donner l'illusion à
soi-même quand je me lève le matin je
suis le docteur Jacky et le soir je sors
en Mister
rde ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire quand
on se lève le matin on a les dures
réalités la barbouse renaissante et puis
des tas de choses horribles dont on
naime pas parler qu'on a'ime pas montrer
il y a nos réalités de chaque jour qui
qui sont pas celles de Monsieur chez
madame tout le monde il faut bien s'en
accommoder voilà là je suis prête à
affronter le grand combat de la vie le
grand combat
journalier vous considérer comme quoi
travesti transsexuel transsexuel
travesti ça veut dire se déguiser je me
déguise pas je vis depuis 30 ans comme
ça vous êtes opéré non la transsexualité
c'est un état et l'opération n'est que
l'aboutissement de cet
état pour moi c'est un
détail si j'ose dire d'une façon imagée
ça n'a jamais été un gros détail c'est
un détail qui n'a jamais servi j'ai fait
l'ablation de ce détail dans ma tête
d'abord parce que je crois que dans ce
dans ce cheminement comme dans d'autres
ce qui est important c'est c'est ce
qu'on a là et puis là bien
sûr pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne
Inna mireum abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche